chaque déclaration il y en a 6 millions
pour paris et dépouillé daté et en
principe on vous en accuse réception
c'est pas gentil ça
voilà à quoi ressemblait un centre des
impôts en 1959
des tonnes de papiers à trier classer
organisé et des percepteurs prête à tout
pour que les contribuables fassent leur
devoir aller écouter chaque fois courir
les payer je vous pris un coup de blanc
sa laïcité il est venu sur l'oreille
d'un sourd
et tous les ans dans les gîtes et les
mêmes sujets sur le fameux métier de
percepteur le métier de percepteur exige
sans doute de la rigueur dans le
caractère mais aussi une certaine
agilité dans le poignet c'est du
véritable travail à la chaîne
mais dans les années 2000 le trésor
public débarque sur internet
dans un premier temps pour aider les
contribuables éloigné des services
publics à remplir leur déclaration
on a eu à ppr de 90 ans donc il est
porté encore bien mais qui avait un
petit problème d'oreille donc le
dialogue a été un petit peu plus
difficile mais écoutez il apparut
enchanté de la formule alors que pour
lui c'est quand même une technologie
tout à fait nouvelle
rapidement la déclaration en ligne
séduit les français
et cette montée en puissance de la
télédéclaration s'accompagne d'une
politique de réduction de postes dans
l'administration fiscale est effectif
que il faut moins de temps pour traiter
l'information en question quand on le
reçoit directement dématérialisés ou non
quand on la reçoit par papier il faut
ouvrir les enveloppes la traiter la
saisir donc à l'évidence il ya des gains
de productivité aujourd'hui en plus de
la télédéclaration devenu obligatoire
depuis 2010 9 s'ajoute le prélèvement à
la source
bilan cinq mille 800 postes supprimés
d'ici à 2022 le percepteur heureux des
années 60 est peut-être en voie de
disparition a vraiment j'ai de la chance
je suis le joyeux percepteur
[Musique]